the Joe Rogan experience speaking of
spooky cardio let's talk about Tony
Ferguson okay that guy's got some guy
and you you have personal experience
with 20 yes yeah this guy's
unfortunately spooky [ __ ] cardio man
III give him a real shot against could
be I give him a real shot okay so um I
do and I don't I and I'm not trying to
take a dig at him I actually am a big
fan of his can I was a big fan of his
before I fought him and I did a lot of
research on him leading up to the fight
I never really showed him any respect up
until like he's just okay he's a little
sloppy's this he's that but once I did
the research on him leading up to our
fight it impressed me what impressed me
was dude the guy can take a shot give a
shot the guy doesn't slow down the guy
doesn't care where the fight goes
anytime you have somebody who doesn't
care what the fight goes it changes the
dynamic of how you approach him because
if you take him down what does that
matter
he don't care yeah he's good with the
darts he's good at the guillotine he's
good with trials he's good with all
those he doesn't care so if he stays on
the feet guess what he keeps his
distance in his range was his long range
push kicks and his and his jabs and his
you know combinations he doesn't care
where the fight goes neither does the
khabib but obviously could be would like
to keep the fight on the ground press
against the fence doing work what he's
done and it continues to work and does
does what he does best
I look for me I feel like the only way
that Tony wins is by a cut hmm I don't
think I don't think I don't think that
he can sub him now I'm not saying it
can't happen
we understand like when cuts happened
you get a little more slippery things
slide in a lot faster okay um especially
in that DARS position like he's really
hit that Darce up from any direction
he'll hit it from he'll hit it from his
guard I'll hit it from his butt he'll
hit it from anywhere yeah so if you're
hanging out if beef doesn't put the
placement of his head in the right spot
it could be a really really tough night
for him
yeah he hits a V salable yeah yeah so
he's got all the intangibles to become
world champion I don't he's already a
former in the interim champion which I
still considered him that he was the
champion
there I have nothing bad to say about
him I just think that physically strong
key is not and I don't want my knocking
him I'm just simply saying strength wise
he is not but Joker I want to shake my
hand his hands will go around yours
probably twice just break he know he's
got such a long fingers that's what
threw me off honestly when I shook his
hand at the weigh-ins his fingers
wrapped all the way around my hand
almost engulfed mine I was like oh [ __ ]
you got really begins well that makes
the power no not just that but one high
when there was a moment there where he
had yet risk control so when I got into
his guard he grabbed my wrist and I
couldn't get my arm free and then in the
meantime he's album in my head and I got
two mercedes-benz cuts right here on the
front of my forehead okay so it was like
right there and then he cut me with the
good elbow when I stepped in on one but
the two mercedes-benz cuts were from him
with the wrist control and him over me
from his guard mmm if khabib gets put in
his guard it could end up being a tough
fight because cuts cuts happen and when
they do happen you have a shaved head
there's nothing stopping them from
flowing right into your into your eyes
your eyebrows are not gonna stop all
that blood and if you recall member the
Joe daddy Stevenson Deniz Edwards fights
that [ __ ] was just squirting out you
know there's a Adam pic alati fight as
well and Bellator where the he had cut
the guy on the top of the head and
literally he gets a rear naked choke sin
and you see blood gulps mm everywhere
and I'm just thinking of myself in a
fight where you you know you shave your
head or your heads your hair is always
really shorter it's you know it's it's
not gonna look good to the to the judges
or to the doctor and things like that
and and bile it and like shop brought
this up this fights in New York yeah
with that [ __ ] lame-ass doctor this
stuff and it gets by yeah yeah oh he's
got a vagina on his eye no one gives a
[ __ ] like god it's still fight right you
know um
they're just they're being extra
cautious in New York right now because
it's a relatively new sport is what I
believe
I believe you know and then I believe
they had that death of that boxer that
was there so then that it just they're
just trying to make sure which I
understand like the safety of the
fighters is most important yeah I would
prefer that being in Vegas yeah yeah I
was in Vegas they let [ __ ] go
[Applause]